in so many ways resettling afghan
refugees isn't straightforward take the
scene we found here at the registered
headquarters of the scottish afghan
society if i would be there they would
kill me too
we met abdul a british army interpreter
who recently fled the taliban's advance
they killed his brother and cousin the
family he left behind are in hiding
my family back in afghanistan they're
hiding they're hiding in caves they're
there
they're spread they they
move to different locations because as
they kill my cousin and they're still
looking for other my family members
he called one of those family members in
afghanistan his brother
we are hiding
because of the taliban
they are searching for us and they want
to kill us my family
but if abdul is a man fleeing the
taliban what of the man who invited him
to this community hall
wahid totokil is the last registered
chairman of the scottish afghan society
he is a taliban supporter
this was him banging on the door of
edinburgh's u.s consulate in 2010
and calling for the death of american
soldiers
more recently his profile has seen him
invited to political fundraisers and
celebration events some attended by
scotland's first minister
a taliban was
they
start defending afghanistan and what
they're showing now in 20 years there
was right
the taliban he says were right include
his brother and their ranks waheed
totokil stresses he speaks for himself
not the scottish afghan society
members of the afghan community here
have told us they condemn his views your
rivals are among them
there has to be action taken against him
should be
what action
it should be you know
the government should
you know investigate
or or if if it's real that his brother
is the commander of taliban or he
supports taliban this he needs to be you
know
just deported
you support the taliban your brother is
a military commander
in the taliban
are you the right man to help
or the wrong man
we are afghan
all brothers
we
the war in afghanistan finish
and
we are now all afghan here we are all
the fuji
all refugees if not all together james
matthews sky news glasgow